اذا كشفت نتائج الانتخابات النصفيه
الامريكيه عن تقدم طفيف للجمهوريين على
الديمقراطيين حتى الان فيما تم الاعلان
عنه في مجلس الشيوخ احتل الجمهوريون 49
مقعدا فيما احتل الديمقراطيون 48 مقعدا
وذلك بعد ان فاز الجمهوريون بولايه
ويسكانسون وتتبقى الان ثلاثه مقاعد في
مجلس الشيوخ هي غير محسومه وهي في جورجيا
اريزونا ونيفادا فياريزون يتقدم
الديمقراطيون عبر السنه الحاليه ماركلي
على الجمهوريه
مصر لكن اعلان فوز الديمقراطيين قد يتاخر
بسبب مشاكل تقنيه تسببت في اغلاق ابواب
اللجان في احد المقاطعات بالامس الامر
الذي اغضب الجمهوريه اما الحزم الحقيقي من
المتوقع ان يكون في جورجيا نيفادا في
الاخيره يتقدم الجمهوري ادم على السيناتور
الديمقراطيه الحاليه
للغايه بين السمه بتوع الديمقراطي الحليب
رافائيل واورنك والجمهوريه المدعوم من
ترامب هيرشي الوكر وبالتالي اعلنت
السلطاته بشكل رسمي انها تتجه لجوله اعاده
الانتخابات في مجلس الشيوخ في السادس من
ديسمبر اي جوله ثانيه هناك اما على صعيد
الانتخابات مجلس النواب فكشفت سي ان عن
حصول الجمهوريين على اربعه مقاعد حتى الان
في ما حصل الديمقراطيون على 187 مقعدا
ولتذ كيف انه للفوز يجب الحصول على 2008
[موسيقى]